The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ROBERT FIELD: This is the first
of two lectures on spectroscopy
and dynamics.
Now, I'm a spectroscopist,
and so this is
the core of what I really love.
And there are a lot
of questions about,
well, what are we trying to do?
And you heard two lectures
from Professor Van Voorhis,
and he talked about ab
initio calculations--
electronic structure
calculations--
where you can get really
close to the exact answer.
And it's really a powerful tool.
And it gets you the truth.
But it gets you so
much truth that you
don't know what to do with it.
And the same thing is
true for spectroscopy.
You get a spectrum.
It contains a huge
amount of information.
And you can take lots
and lots of spectra.
But what are we trying to do?
When I was a
graduate student, we
were doing a unique super
high resolution spectroscopy.
And so we thought what
we were generating
was excellent tests for
quantitative theory.
And if, in those days, I went
to a lecture by a theorist,
they were saying,
we're generating stuff
to check against experiment.
And it's a circle, and that's
not what we're trying to do.
The theory and the experiment
are just the beginning.
And you can start
from either extreme.
What we want is, how
does it all work?
What is going on?
Can we build a picture, which
is intuitive and checkable and
predictive, so that
we can say, oh, yeah.
If we want to know something,
we can get to it this way.
And the purpose
of this lecture is
to not provide a
textbook view of spectra,
but to give you a sense of
how you can get to stuff
that challenge your intuition.
What we want to do as
scientists is to be surprised.
We want to do a good experiment
or do a good calculation.
And we want to find that the
result is not what we expected.
And we can figure out why
it's not what we expected.
And that's never conveyed
in any textbooks.
Now, this lecture is based on
my little book of lecture notes.
And I have a number
of copies of it.
And if people have a
strong wish to have a copy,
you can have one.
I can give it to you.
And a lot of this lecture is
based on the first chapter
of this book.
But many of the topics are
developed throughout the book.
OK.
So this is a two
lecture sequence,
and the first half will cover
this stuff on this board.
And it's in the
notes, so you don't
have to copy all this stuff.
I just want you to
see where we're going.
So I've already
talked a little bit
about experiment versus theory.
They complement each other.
We can use theory to
devise an experiment, which
is path breaking.
Or we can use an experiment
to challenge the theorist
to calculate a
new kind of thing.
And I hope that some of
these things, those ideas,
present themselves
in this lecture.
And it's really important
that if there's something
that you don't
understand or don't
capture the importance of,
you should ask me a question.
I really want to talk
about what it's all for.
OK.
So I'm going to
talk about spectra,
and it will be what kinds--
rotation, vibration, electronic,
and other ramifications.
And going from atom to
diatomic to polyatomic
to condensed phase.
Each step along this path
leads to new complexities
and new insights.
Then I'll talk about,
OK, we got a spectrum.
What do we expect to
be in the spectrum?
Well, one of the
things that's important
is the transition selection
rules or transition rules.
Selection rules correspond
to an operator-- eigenvalues
of an operator-- that commutes
with the exact Hamiltonian.
And those correspond
to symmetries.
And there are propensity
rules like, OK,
which transitions are
going to be strong
and which are going to be weak?
And a beautiful example
of propensity rules
are based on the
Franck-Condon principle.
And the Franck-Condon principle
is one of the first keys
you use to unlock
what's in a spectrum,
or what a molecule is doing.
Because it's the first
level of complexity
that is presented to
you in the spectrum.
What are the vibrational bands,
and how do we assign them,
and what are they telling us?
There is a very different kind
of information in an absorption
spectrum, because it's
always from the lowest
electronic state, lowest
vibrational level.
And so there's a
simplicity, because
of a kind of state selection.
And in emission, it's a
very different ballgame.
Because in the gas
phase, the emission
is from many different levels.
In the condensed
phase, it's not.
Why?
OK.
And then we get to dynamics.
And the main thing I want
to do in these two lectures
is to whet your
appetite for dynamics.
And there are many kinds
of dynamics ranging
from a simple two level
quantum beat to intramolecular
vibrational redistribution.
Which you can understand
by perturbation theory
to the strange behavior of
electronically excited states
losing their
ability to fluoresce
not because the molecule breaks,
but because the bright state--
that's an important concept--
the bright state is something.
It's not an eigenstate.
It's a special state
that we understand well.
It's one of the things that
we build perturbation theory
around.
The bright state mixes into an
enormous number of dark states.
And the molecule
forgets that it knows
how to fluoresce because
the different components,
different eigenstates dephase.
And that is a beautiful theory.
And when I was a
graduate student,
this theory of
radiationless transitions--
Bixon-Jortner theory--
was just created
and many people
didn't believe it.
They thought molecules,
big molecules,
they're really easy to
be quenched by collision
and the loss of the
ability to fluoresce
or the absence of
fluorescence was somehow
collision related as opposed
to a physical process.
So there's lots of good stuff.
And some of the good stuff
is Ahmed Zewail's Nobel Prize
where he claims--
and that's why he got the
Nobel Prize, because people
believed that claim.
Now, I'm not saying it's wrong.
But part of getting
famous is to have
a package, which you can sell.
And he sold the
daylights out of it.
And he calls it clocking
real dynamics in real time.
And it's basically wave packets.
But they're wave packets
doing neat stuff.
And for example,
one way a molecule
can lose the
ability to fluoresce
is because the molecule breaks.
And what is the mechanism
by which a molecule breaks?
Does the bond just simply
break or is there some motion
that precedes that?
And what Zewail did
was to show what
are the motions that
lead the molecule
into the region of state
space where the bond breaks.
And, of course, if you want
to manipulate molecules,
you either want to get to
those regions or avoid them.
And so there's all
sorts of insight there.
OK.
Now this is what I believe.
That if you understand
small molecules,
you will see examples
of everything
you need to know to deal with
almost any dynamical process
in chemistry.
Now, this is certainly
an exaggeration,
but this has been
my motto for years.
And so I really stress
the small molecules.
And it's not that small
molecules are really hard.
They're really
beautiful, and they
do enough so that you can
anticipate what you need
to deal with bigger molecules.
So let's begin.
OK.
So what is a molecule?
As chemists, we
would never think
of a molecule as a bag
of nuclei and electrons.
We wouldn't think of it
as a bag of atoms either.
We believe in chemical bonds.
This is an important thing.
It's not a conserved quantity.
Bonds can break.
But we believe that bonds
tell an important story.
And so almost all of our
pictures for complicated
phenomena are based on the--
I hesitate to use
the word sanctity--
but the importance of bonds.
OK.
We start-- I'm
going to erase this,
because I've made
my point, and it's
embarrassing to keep
emphasizing my secret motto.
But it is true.
OK.
We have the Born-Oppenheimer
approximation.
And this is very
important, because we can't
solve a three body problem.
We can solve a two body problem.
But we have molecules,
which are consisting
of nuclei and electrons.
And this Born-Oppenheimer
approximation
enables us to separate the
nuclear part of the problem
from the electronic
part of the problem.
Because these two things move
at very different velocities.
And so it's a profound
simplification.
We get potential energy curves
or potential energy surfaces.
And that is the repository
of essentially everything
we want to know.
If we know the
potential surface,
we can begin to do
almost anything.
And certainly for
a big molecule,
it's not just a simple
curve like this.
If you have N atoms, there's
3N minus 6 vibrational modes.
And well, that sounds terrible.
But even for this, you have
essentially an infinite number
of vibrational levels
and an infinite number
of rotational levels.
And so if you have a
polyatomic molecule,
you have 3N minus 6
infinities of infinities.
So you're not wanting
to get everything.
You want to generate
enough information
to be able to calculate
anything you want.
And sometimes, you
make approximations
and you're not sure that
those approximations are good.
And you want them to break.
You want to discover
something new.
So the Born-Oppenheimer
approximation,
we go from clamped
nuclei calculation
where the-- since
the nuclei moves slow
compared to the electrons, well,
let's not let them move at all.
And then we build a
perturbation theory picture
where we let them move.
And we can deal with that
because we understand
vibrations and rotations.
OK.
So we have a potential
energy surface.
And there are things
that we can anticipate
about a potential
energy surface.
And LCAO-MO theory
enables you to say
a lot of important things about
the potential energy surface.
So it provides a
qualitative framework.
And so from molecular
orbital theory--
and this is not what Professor
Van Voorhis talked about.
This is the baby stuff.
And we don't expect to
get the exact answer.
But we do expect to be
able to explain trends.
Trends within a molecule and
between related molecules.
So this provides a
framework for expectations.
And there are things that
we get like bond order.
And we talk about orbitals
that are bonding, non-bonding,
and antibonding.
And this comes directly
out of the simple ideas.
Recall when we had
atom with a hydrogen,
the hydrogen doesn't
make pi bonds.
And so they're pi orbitals for
the atom A, which have nothing
to interact with.
And they're usually non-bonding.
So we have these
sorts of things.
We have spN hybridization.
And this is just telling
you if a molecule wants
to make the maximum number
of bonds, you do something.
And if it's sp
cubed, you have four
tetrahedrally arranged bonds.
And if it's sp cubed, sp squared
is planar with 120 degrees.
These things tell you something
about geometric expectations.
Now, molecules don't
follow the rules exactly,
but they come pretty close.
And so if you have
some reason to believe
that a particular
hybridization is appropriate,
then you have certain
expectations for the geometry
and how that's going to
present itself in the spectrum.
So bond order's related
to internuclear distance
and vibrational frequencies.
Sp hybridization has
to do with geometry,
and all of these things
are really important.
So we have a potential surface.
And let's say this
is a boldface thing,
implying that there are 3N
minus 6 different displacement
coordinates.
This potential encodes
the normal modes.
What's a normal mode?
Well, it's a classical
mechanical concept.
And it basically
corresponds to situations
where all of the atoms
move at the same frequency
in each normal mode.
And these normal modes each
has an expected frequency
and expected geometry.
Because if it's a
polyatomic molecule,
you have not just
two things moving.
They'll always be moving
at the same frequency.
But you have three
or four or 100.
And OK.
So you learn about the shape
of the potential and the force
constants and so on.
Now, we have the
rotational structure.
Now, molecules are
not rigid rotors.
But it's useful to think about
molecules as rigid rotors
to develop a basis set
for describing rotation.
And perturbation
theory enables us
to describe the energy levels
of a non-rigid vibrating rotor.
And it's straightforward.
It may be ugly, but it tells
you how you take information
from the spectrum
and learn about, say,
the internuclear
distance dependence
of molecular constants
like a spin orbit constant.
Or some hyperfine constant.
Or just the rotational constant.
And it's a simple thing.
And I'm toying with the idea
of using this sort of problem
on the exam.
And I'm not sure whether
I did on the second exam.
But if I did, you'll have a
chance to redeem yourself.
OK.
Then in the gas phase,
nothing much happens.
You can have collisions, but
the time between collisions
can be controlled by what
the pressure you use.
And so you can sort
of think about the gas
phase as something where
the molecules are isolated.
And another way of saying
that is the expectation
value of the Hamiltonian in
any state is time independent.
The Hamiltonian is energy.
Energy is conserved.
And unless there are collisions,
energy will be conserved.
And so.
But in the condensed phase,
you have lot of collisions.
They're very fast.
And so one big difference
between the gas phase
and the condensed phase is
energy is not conserved.
And it's not conserved
at different rates
for different kinds of motions.
And you want to understand that.
OK.
So now let's talk about
the kinds of spectra.
We have rotational spectra.
And that usually is in the
micro region of the spectrum.
And it requires that
the electric dipole
moment be not equal to zero.
I'll talk about this
some more in a minute.
We have vibration.
And vibrational spectrum
is in the infrared.
And the requirement
for vibration
is that the dipole moment--
which is a vector
quantity if you don't
have a diatomic molecule--
changes with displacements,
each of the normal modes.
And so we have a
molecule like CO2.
CO2 does not have a dipole
moment at equilibrium.
It's a linear
molecule, symmetric.
But it can do this and that
is a change in dipole moment.
It can do this and that
produces a new dipole moment.
Or produces a dipole moment.
And it can do this,
which does not.
So you have different
modes, which are infrared
active and infrared inactive.
And it's related to
this dipole moment.
Now notice, I put a
vector sign on it.
It corresponds to motion,
directions in the body frame
where the dipole moment changes.
When you do this,
the dipole moment
is perpendicular to the axis.
When you do this,
it's along the axis.
And so there is stuff--
really a lot of
stuff-- just looking
at what vibrational
modes are active.
And then there's electronic.
And that's mostly in
the visible and UV.
But the electronic spectrum
could be in the X-ray region
even.
But mostly, molecules
break when they get outside
of the ordinary UV region.
And so there's not much there.
OK.
What's needed.
Well, what's needed is the
electronic transition moment.
Let's call this e1, e2.
Going from two different
electronic states,
there is an electric
dipole transition moment,
which is not equal to zero.
So H2, which has no
vibrational spectrum
and no rotational spectrum
has an electronic spectrum.
Everything has an
electronic spectrum.
OK.
Now, a diatomic molecule.
Here is sort of a
template for everything
a diatomic molecule can do.
Now, they're cleverer than this.
But this is sort
of in preparation
for dealing with
greater complexity.
And then we can have up here.
OK.
So this is the
electronic ground state.
And normally, if you
have a diatomic molecule,
you can predict what is
the electronic ground state
and how is it going to look--
how is its potential
curve going to look
relative to the excited states.
That's something you
should be able to do
using LCAO-MO theory.
OK.
So this is the ground state.
This is the repulsive state.
And usually, the
ground state correlates
with ground state of the atoms.
And so here we have
a repulsive state,
which also correlates with
the ground state of the atom.
So this is an excited state, and
that correlates with an excited
state of the atoms.
And this is AB plus an electron.
So that's one way
the molecule breaks.
And this dotted curve
represents Rydberg
states They're Rydberg
states converging
to every rotation vibration
level of this excited state.
And it can be complicated.
But it's beautiful,
because I know
the magic decoder for how do
you deal with Rydberg states.
Because there's a lot
of them, but they're
closely related to each other.
And we can exploit
that relationship
in guiding an experiment.
And so here, now we
have a curve crossing
between a repulsive
state and a bound state.
And that leads to what
we call predissociation.
So the vibrational
level of this state--
which would normally be bound
above the curve crossing--
are not bound.
And that's encoded
in the spectrum too.
And so for more
complicated molecules,
they're going to be these curve
crossings or surface crossings.
And we want to know how
do we deal with them,
and what is a diatomic-like
way of dealing with them.
And the important thing is
at that internuclear distance
where the curves cross, then
you could be at a level--
starting at a level
on this state--
the bound state.
And it will have the same
momentum at the crossing radius
as the repulsive state.
And that's where it goes.
That's where it leaks out.
I mean, we're normally used
to thinking about processes--
non-radiative processes,
all kinds of processes--
as an integral overall space.
But because the
momenta are the same
on the two curves
at this radius,
they can go freely
from one to the other.
The molecules can go freely
We get a tremendous
simplification.
And this is something that is
always ignored in textbooks
and is a profound insight.
Because you know exactly
where things happen and why
they happen.
And so you can arrange
the information
to describe what's
going on at this point.
And this is where semi-classical
theory is really valuable.
Because not only do you know
that you have stationary phase
at this point.
But you know what the spatial
oscillation frequency is.
Because the spatial
oscillation frequency is H--
or the wavelength-- is h over p.
And you know what the
momentum is at this point.
And so you know
where the nodes are.
How far the nodes are apart
and what the amplitude is here.
And so it tells you
exactly what you
want to know in
order to describe
this non-radiative process.
And my belief is that almost
all of the complex things that
molecules do happen at
a predictable region
in coordinated space.
And you can get the information
you need to understand them,
because all of a
sudden, the molecule
is behaving in a kind
of classical way.
And we're entitled to think
locally rather than globally.
OK.
I'm going very slowly.
We may get through most of what
I planned to talk about today.
I have 11 pages of
notes, and this is--
I'm on page three.
So maybe we'll take off.
OK.
So how do you do spectra?
Well, in the old days,
you had some light source
like a candle, and
you had a lens,
and you had an absorption cell.
And there would be some
sort of a spectrometer here.
Could be a grading.
It could be a prism.
It could be anything.
But it's something
that says, OK, I
looked at the
selected wavelengths
at which the gas in
this cell removed light
from the continuum.
And then you have a detector,
which in the old days
was a photographic plate.
But it could be a
photo multiplier,
and you're looking
at the spectrum
by scanning the grading
or something like that.
And so what you would
get is some kind
of a record where you have dark
regions corresponding to where
there has been no absorption
and, well, actually it
would be the other way around.
There'd be bright
regions, because there'd
be no exposure of the emulsion
on the plate and dark regions
where there--
yes-- where the light hits.
OK.
So but we're much
cleverer than this.
And we can do all sorts
of wonderful things.
And again, I've been
around for a long time
and lasers were just
beginning to be used
when I was a graduate student.
And I was one of the
first small molecules
spectroscopists to use lasers.
But not as a graduate student.
I wanted them, but we had such--
lasers were so terrible in the
region between 1965 and 1971
when I was a graduate student.
And so lasers were things to be
admired, but hardly to be used.
But one of the crucial
things was dye lasers.
Because these guys
are monochromatic,
and they can be tuned and tuned
continuously over a wide region
of the spectrum.
And so that's way better than
a candle or a light bulb.
Because it's monochromatic,
and you're asking one
question at a time as
you tune the laser.
Now, lasers enable you to do
many kinds of experiments.
You can simply tune the
laser through a series
of transitions, and
you get fluorescence
every time the laser tunes
through a transition.
And if one laser is good,
two lasers are better.
And so you can do
all sorts of things
like suppose this spectrum
is really complicated.
And you want to be
able to simplify it.
And so you can do a double
resonance experiment
where you tune this
laser to one line
and then you tune this laser
through a series of transition.
That spectrum is
going to be simple,
and it's going to be
telling you who this was.
And there's just
no end of tricks.
And often, instead of
detecting the fluorescence,
you tune the laser.
Let's do this.
And so starting here is some
kind of a continuum, ionization
continuum.
And so you have this
photon being used twice.
One here and one to take it
above the ionization limit.
And so you have an
excitation, which you do
want to know how strong it is.
And so you might monitor
the fluorescence.
But you don't know who
this is, and you find out
by tuning this.
But you would detect
the excitation here
by subsequent ionization.
It's easy to collect ions.
Every ion you produce,
you can detect.
Every photon you produce,
you can't detect.
Because you have a solid
angle consideration and photo
multipliers are not perfect.
And so ionization detection
is way more sensitive.
So you can do that
kind of thing.
You can also do--
this is a kind of
sequential excitation.
You could imagine doing
an experiment where
you have an energy level
here, and you have a laser,
which is not on resonance.
That's a coherent process.
It uses the oscilltor strength
at this level to get to here.
And that's related to many other
kinds of current experiments.
And that's neat.
Now, we're recording
spectra, and we need
to know what the rules are.
And so there are certain
transitions that are allowed
and certain transitions
that are forbidden.
Now, I talked about the
transition requirements
for rotation, vibration,
and electronic.
But let's just talk about
the electronic spectrum,
because the other
two are simple.
The transition operator is
equal to the sum over electrons
of e times r sub i.
It's a one electron operator.
And that means if we
have wave functions which
are Slater determinates of
spin orbitals like 2s alpha.
This one electron
operator can only
have a non-zero matrix
element if the two states
differ by one spin orbital.
That's a big simplification.
And so one can actually use
this to selectively access
different kinds of states
by designing an experiment.
But the important thing is that
for electronic transitions,
we have the selection rule
delta so is equal to 1.
Not 2.
Not 0.
And now, the operator doesn't
have any spin involved with it.
And so that means
delta s equals 0.
You did not change, you did
not go from a singlet state
to a triplet state.
And the only way you can
get from a singlet state
to a triplet state is
if the triplet state is
perturbed by a singlet state.
So this picture I drew where I
had a repulsive state crossing
through a bound state, it might
have been that one of those
was a triplet.
And as a result, and
the other is a singlet,
and you have spin
orbit interactions,
and you get extra states,
extra lines appearing.
But you get this
wonderful selection rule.
There is also for
the electric dipole
that we have plus
to minus parity.
Now what's parity?
I don't like talking
about parity,
because the useful definition
leads to complexity.
But basically,
parity corresponds
to the symmetry, the inversion
symmetry in the laboratory
frame.
Now, you say, well, a molecule
doesn't have any inversion
symmetry.
But space is isotopic.
And so you can go from a
left handed to a right handed
coordinate system.
And that's what happens
when you invert space.
And so you can classify
levels according
to whether they're odd
or even with respect
to space inversion.
This is close to the truth.
This is close to all you need
to know unless you're actually
going to do stuff with
the parity operator.
But it's a useful
way of saying, OK,
I put parity labels on things.
I learned how to do
that, and that's enough.
Now, you follow selection rules
where good quantum numbers
are conserved.
Or they change in a
way that you predict
based on the way you
did the experiment.
A good quantum
number, I remind you,
is the eigenvalue of an
operator that commutes
with the exact Hamiltonian.
There are very few rigorously
good quantum numbers.
But if a molecule
has any symmetry,
group theory tells
you a bunch of things
that commute with
the Hamiltonian,
and it gives you
symmetry labels.
And that's very important
in inorganic chemistry
where you have either molecules
with symmetry or molecules
with atoms with ligands in
a symmetric arrangement.
And since the transition
is on the center atom
usually that you can classify
them using group theory as
allowed or forbidden.
So if we have an
electronic transition,
the easiest thing to observe
is vibrational bands.
If you have a relatively
low resolution spectrum,
you're going to see
vibrational bands.
You have to work harder to
see the rotational transitions
in each vibrational band, but
you get an enormous amount
of qualitative
information just looking
at the vibrational bands.
Because the vibrational
bands encode the difference
between the ground state
potential and the excited state
potential.
Now, this is a
universal notation.
Ground state is
always double prime.
Upper state is
always single prime.
Very strange, but
that's the way it is.
And so if these
potentials are different,
the vibrational bands
encode the difference.
And this comes from the
Franck-Condon principle, which
says nuclei move slowly,
electrons move fast.
The transition is an
instantaneous process,
as far as the nuclei
are concerned.
And so there's no change
in nuclear coordinates,
and there is no change
in nuclear momentum.
This is what's in
all the textbooks,
and nobody ever
talks about this,
because we don't really normally
know or think about momentum.
But we do know what it is.
We do know what the operator is.
And we know that
kinetic energy is
related to the momentum
squared over 2 times the mass.
So what is this?
This means transitions
are vertical.
In other words, if we have
a pair of electronic states,
we draw these vertical lines.
Not slanting lines.
This means momentum
is conserved.
And this, here at
this vertical point,
we have this much momentum.
And, well, there's
the same amount here.
Now usually, this just means--
the delta p is equal to 0--
means that of all the
strong transitions,
turning point to turning point
transitions are the strongest.
Because at a turning point, the
vibrational amplitude is large.
But there's more
to it than that,
because there are
secondary maxima
in the vibrational
transition intensities.
These correspond to stationary
phase between the initial state
and the final state.
And so in addition to the
strongest transitions,
you get other transitions that
you can explain by this delta p
equals 0.
Now, you don't know
anything when you start.
You know something maybe
about the ground state.
And this could be a
polyatomic molecule
if we're just
looking at one mode.
And suppose we have
an excited state where
the vibrational
frequency is the same.
In other words, there is no
change in bonding character.
And so what you end
up getting is just
the zero to zero
transition in absorption.
Or if you have many vibrational
levels up here, you see v to v,
delta v equals 0.
Now, you could
have a bound state,
and it's usually true that the
excited state is less bound.
And so you would have--
the Franck-Condon active
region corresponds
to turning point to turning
point in the lower state.
So I shouldn't draw this.
Let's draw a
vertical transition.
Well, I missed.
Let me just start again.
So we have an excited state,
and we have a ground state.
Ground state is bound.
And this is v equal 0.
And so we go from here to there.
So if the excited
state is less bound,
it's a larger inner nucleus and
smaller vibrational frequency.
We have many vibrational
levels accessed
by the Franck-Condon principle.
And if we have, in
the other sense,
we have an excited state, which
is more bound than the ground
state then the Franck-Condon
region is narrower.
Because this wall
is nearly vertical.
You have more transitions
when it's displaced this way.
And this branch of the potential
is nearly much flatter,
and you have fewer
transitions here.
So the vibrational pattern
tells you qualitatively from the
get go whether you're going to
a more bound or a less bound
state.
That's very useful information.
Now, you want to go further.
You want to say, oh,
well, I'm observing
a bunch of vibrational
levels in the excited state.
What are their quantum numbers?
Are we seeing the v
equals zero level?
How do we know what vibrational
level we're observing?
Or levels?
And we can calculate
Franck-Condon factors.
But you can do many things.
So I mean, if you have
a situation like this,
you might not get to the
lowest vibrational level.
But if you have a
situation like this,
you probably will get to the
lowest vibrational level.
So one way to get
vibrational numbering
is seeing the vibrational
pattern terminate.
That's a good sign
it's v equals 0.
If it terminates
abruptly, it's v equal 0.
But if it terminates
slowly, you're not sure.
But there are other really
wonderful things about this.
And you can do
isotope separation.
Isotope shifts.
Since the vibrational
frequency is
the square root of k over mu,
we can change and reduce mass.
That changes which
vibrational bands you observe,
and it changes it in
a quantitative way,
and so you can often
use that to tell.
Another thing you
can do is to now.
If you have an excited state,
the vibrational wave function
is going to look like this.
And there's a node
here, and a node here,
and node here, node
here, node here.
And so if we're looking at
the vibrational progression
observed from such a
level, the intensities
will have minima corresponding
to how many nodes there
are in the excited state.
And the number of nodes is the
vibrational quantum number.
So there are lots
of ways of doing it.
And then there is
something else.
If you observe at
moderately low resolution
a vibrational band in
an electronic spectrum,
it will have the peculiar
shape like that or like that.
This is called a band head.
And it corresponds to
the fact that because
the rotational constants in
the upper and lower state
are different, one
of the branches--
you have delta J equals
plus or minus 1, 0.
And the delta J plus 1 is
called the R branch and minus 1
is called the P branch.
And delta J of 0 is
called the Q branch.
Now, these two guys
are such that depending
on the sign of the
difference in B values,
you get ahead on the
high frequency side
or ahead on the
low frequency side.
Well, actually, it's
the other way around.
But it tells you then
the rotational constant,
which is also a signal of
how bound the state is.
The rotational constant-- the
shading of these band heads--
confirms your
vibrational assignment.
And typically, if you have a
smaller vibrational frequency,
you'll also have a smaller
rotational constant.
It's not always true.
And it's always interesting
when it doesn't happen.
And so the vibrational bands
have this asymmetric shape
unless the rotational constant
upstairs and downstairs
is the same.
And then you have a branch
going this way and a branch
going this way.
And a gap in the middle
that might be filled
with some Q branch lines.
And the Q branch lines
tell you, oh, yeah, that
was a transition where the
lambda, the projection of L
on the internuclear
axis changed.
And if it doesn't
have this Q branch,
it'll tell you this
delta lambda equals 0.
All sorts of stuff.
And if you have no
sign of band heads,
but just this double
hump structure,
it tells you that the rotational
constant is about the same as
in the ground state.
And it tells you also that
the vibrational frequency is
expected to be about the same.
I better stop.
So as soon as you go to
polyatomic molecules.
Instead of having just one
vibration, you have 3n minus 6.
And so 3n minus 6 downstairs,
3n minus 6 upstairs,
that looks bad.
But only some of the
vibrational modes
correspond to a
distortion from--
a difference in geometry
between the ground
state and the excited state.
And so most of the
vibrational modes
correspond to
identical frequencies.
And what we call that
is Franck-Condon dark.
Because the only transitions
that are allowed are delta v
equals 0 for that mode.
And so only the
modes that correspond
to a change in structure
appear as long progressions.
And so there are only a
few, and so the spectrum
of a polyatomic molecule
is not too much different
from a diatomic
molecule, because
of the small number of
Franck-Condon active modes.
But you look closer and
you see big differences.
OK.
So well, we'll talk more
about this on Friday.
And we might go
to three lectures
on this, because
this is really--
you know the whole
point of this course
is to be able to understand
how molecules talk to us.